so welcome to my talk on systems
programming in 80s
so before I start with like ATS syntax
or how things work anything like that
here's the elevator pitch for ATS
it's an ml but it's not a standard ml
but it's got algebraic data types and
pattern matching and all that good stuff
functional programming is fully
supported because tail calls are
actually optimized in ATS and it
actually also supports mutual recursion
but the thing that I think that ATS
really brings to the table that sets it
apart from all the other languages is
exactly the same performance and memory
predictability of C notice I didn't say
that it runs as fast as C or uses as
little memory of C I'm making a stronger
statement than that I'm saying you have
the exact same control as C all that
stuff that you do in C pointer
arithmetic allocating D allocating
freeing stack allocation all of that
stuff that comes back but there's this
whiz-bang type system that makes all
that safe so if you use the type system
right you'll never walk off the end of
an array you will never double free
something you will never have dangling
stack pointers and you will always free
all your resources and I think that's a
really powerful thing to have it just D
compiles to C and except for tail calls
there's no real optimization and GCC or
your favorite C compiler does the rest
which is why for the longest time it was
always on top of the language benchmarks
it wasn't always in the top four if I
was always like C C++ ADA 80s Fortran
and now rust right but for some reason
it was taken down in 2015 and kind of
pisses me off I've know what actually I
now know why I was taken down because
somebody the audience just told me but I
didn't know why until just now but a
couple of big things that like ATS
brings to the table are like linear
logic to manage resources so what is
linear logic so if you create a resource
you allocate memory you open a file
handle you open a database handle that's
a resource so when you create that
at the type level you get this thing
called a proof object a proof object is
a type level proof that this resource
actually exists and when you want to use
the resource like you want to read from
a file or something like that you have
to pass that proof object manually into
the function that's reading from the
file and that's how the type system
knows that this resource is still viable
so for example here I have a function
called bar and in the let block I have
this function called open file that
takes some file path and returns FD
which is a file descriptor and some
extra syntax which you've probably never
seen before and get used to that
[Music]
there's this pipe and to the left of
this pipe is this thing called awesome
proof awesome proof only exists at the
type level so when I'm trying to read
from that file I have to pass that
awesome proof back into the read file so
that the type system knows that the file
descriptor is still open and when I
close the file I pass this proof in that
proof gets consumed and is no longer
available anywhere so that means that
even though file descriptor may be in
scope if that proof has been consumed
there's no way for another function to
read off of a bad file handle or a bad
memory address or anything like that
an 80s really doubles down on this for
memory so there's like specialized
syntax that says there's a pointer at
this address of this size of this type
that may or may not be initialized
that's like five characters or something
like that so and this is how type check
pointers matech works in 80s this is how
you can never read off the end of an
array because you don't have a proof for
it the other big thing that ATS brings
to the table is this idea of refinement
types so refinement types are a way of
constraining a large type so here's this
function foo it takes an int it does a
huge type it can go anywhere from 0 to
like whatever the max value of enters on
your system so
want to constrain that sometimes so you
modify that with this short it's called
a sort in 80s such that sort as an INT
where n is greater than zero and n is
less than 10 so what this means is that
you can never call foo with an integer
that's not between zero and ten the type
checker makes you do that so between
this and linear logic you can do a lot
of like the C style stuff safely in 80s
that you couldn't do in other
programming languages okay I've just
sold you the holy grail okay
unfortunately 80s is the most difficult
language I've ever learned in my entire
life I'm not going to Gaslight you the
examples that I'm going to show you or
hard and there's that's why it's called
a not-so-gentle reduction because I'm
just passing the book and saying I don't
know how to make this simple and some of
this is essential complexity right
because it's combining none of these
things are trivial refinement types not
trivial linear logic not trivial proofs
not trivial C definitely not trivial
right and it's a research language by
definition it's funded in part by the
NSF there's one P I in Boston University
like doing 99% of the commits right so
when you put all these things together
the first thing that goes out the window
is programmer organ onyx all right so
80s is a tough language to work it's
really hard there's no easy story
there's no new comer onboarding right
there's no Royal Road there's barely a
royal cliff like
okay there's a tiny community if they
were all gathered in a bar I could buy
them around you know and because of that
the documentation is really sparse but I
presented anyway because I think it has
some amazing ideas that I'm not seeing
anywhere else and I think that we should
be taking these ideas are running with
them either cannibalize 80s or better
yet gather some resources and make 80s
itself commercially viable like clean up
some of the syntax all of this stuff
right cool so the answer to your
question is 80s ready for production to
quote the great Travis Browne it's ready
for production if production is ready
for it you know so the easiest way to
get started with 80s is I think with the
sea Interop so here's a generic swap
function and see that swaps to avoid
pointers
yes I realized sending size T as an
argument as bad don't ask me on that one
because the point is that all I have to
do to include that into an 80s file is
stick it inside of these percentage
curly delimiters and basically when the
C code generator gets to that point it
just takes whatever's inside of those
delimiters and jams it into the output
file right there
it's exhibits exactly that simple all
right and here's a foreign function call
to that swap function it takes two
pointers and a size T and the thing to
notice here is that all of this all of
the base types in 80s are exactly the
same as C pointers are pointers size
teaser size T's incidence Long's are
lungs
there is no marshalling and unmarshal
overhead we're also going to need malloc
and that's a size T that returns a
pointer right but and here we run it
okay so I'm allocating a couple of
chunks of memory and I'm swapping it
cool here I'm allocating an integer all
good
lovely here I'm allocating a double
that's not good and here I'm calling
swap and telling it that both things are
double that's super not good
and I'm not even cleaning up right okay
so 80s can totally mimic see bugs and
all you can port your Z code to the
highest fidelity to 80s by just you can
port it line by line if you want to the
type system goes to 11 it goes all the
way down to C okay so this the upside is
this facilitates gradual migration in a
way that's actually I think easier to do
than something like trust you know you
can port the entire Linux kernel over to
ETS if you wanted to but we can do
better than that
so here's the old swap function let's
remove the arguments and give ourselves
some space because ATS needs space lots
of space so swap is parameterised on
some type of type T at ype that is not a
typo
that means a type of unspecified size
because ATS is obsessed with the size of
the things that you pass in so you're
passing in a generic type it's like okay
you have to tell me whether it's a size
something or you don't know what the
size is and that's the key word for I
have no clue what the size of that thing
is because the generic argument okay so
I'm passing in an address where the
address has to be greater than no
another address where the address has to
be greater than now and now the actual
arguments right I have an eye which is a
pointer to a non-null address I have a J
which is a pointer to a non-null address
I have the S which is a size argument
that takes this type size of underscore
t that is parameterised on the tee at
ype type that i just passed in in order
to be type safe about what kinds of
types of engineering so i can't just
like pass in five as a size argument to
like the swap function that's and then
we see that familiar pipe again so
remember in the example where i was
reading from a file descriptor
I was using that pipe 2d structure
approve so when open when open file
returned a file descriptor it also
returned a proof I can also use the
similar syntax to pass improves so
here's special syntax that says that
there's something of type a at address
l1 I'm passing in that proof and
something of type a at address l2 also
passing in that proof the return type is
void but it also returns two proofs that
there's an a of l1 and an a at l2 why
does it do that because ATS by default
will consume proofs if unless you tell
it not to those proofs are gone and not
available for use anymore so if you
actually want to use those briefs you
have to return them by the way there's a
special there's special syntax for
everything but there's like special
syntax we're saying don't touch these
proofs they're fine don't worry about it
but to be explicit that's how our ups
works
so here's malloc make ourselves some
space pass in that one size type
parameter
past net size argument which is
parameterised on size of a on size of t
and pass back a pointer to some location
L such that there is something of type a
at L that is possibly uninitialized
that's what that question mark means or
it gets better and an address that's
greater than null
okay cool so now we have our main
function
we're allocating an integer we're
getting it we're getting back a pointer
to that integer I and a proof that I
exists allocating an integer getting a
pointer to that and a proof that that
exists that's J and now I want to set
that pointer to something I want to set
I'd 1 so I said I don't want but I also
have to pass in a proof that I exist it
consumes that proof it's a void function
but it returns a new proof that
something else can use and the same
thing with J passed passing the proof of
J to set J equal to 2 and get a new
proof pfj 1 now here I have swap that
takes IJ and a size R parameter but I
have to give it the new proof PFI 1 and
pfg oh that should be PF j 1 sorry typo
and hands back a it's what it's a void
function it hands back a proof of p fi 2
and PF j 2 right because we need those
to free the resources here I'm freeing I
passing in that proof of p fi 2 and 3
and J passing in that proof of p FJ 2 if
I didn't have those freeze that would be
a type error because any unconsumed
proof left lying around after the
program is complete is a type error
because according to ATS that's a
leaking resource of some sort somewhere
you have to clean up all your proofs
like you have to clean your blank
because there's starving type systems
that don't have proofs or something
so the same thing I don't free that I
get I get a type error I pass in
something size of something other than
it I get a type error
I don't pointers that I get a type error
basically everything that can go wrong
with swap is a type error except for if
I want swap ji instead of IJ that's
actually not a type error there's no
amount of like typing that would
actually make that work because of type
blindness so I don't care how it was
bang your type system is please test
your code cuz there's something that it
doesn't see but here's the original code
here's all the code it's dedicated just
to proof threading right and there's
some hash blur in the bag going type
level state monad or whatever you know
but nts's like lol how about implicit
proofs and syntactic sugar because that
solves everything
so here's an idiomatic swap in 80s that
bank p1 syntax means there's a pointer
called p1 bang means dereference this
but first look around and scope for a
proof that might work and use it which
is absolutely no bug vectors here
whatsoever but but the story is that
like implicit some syntactic sugar solve
all UX problems so remember that if
you're designing a if you're designing a
language let's take a huge step back at
this point anybody here overwhelmed
because that was a crap ton of syntax
right brief there's more but it's coming
and I haven't even shown you the type
errors yet what
and I'm not going to because they look
like those like like taunting code
messages that serial-killer send the
cops that's it's it's rough but at the
same time I still like think that you
should look at ATS not for hey adopt us
now but this idea of passing proofs
around is so powerful I think I think
it's the future of systems programming
like rust has this idea of linear logic
right but all of the linear logic stuff
the cool stuff is back behind sort of
the lifetime analysis mechanism and sort
of the borrowed checker and stuff like
that I want first-class access to those
proofs I don't want them back behind
something for the sake of some error
message because I think I can have much
better designs much more flexible
designs if I have access to that stuff
and I think that if you were designing a
systems programming language which one
of you probably is like you know right
please do this like please take from
this okay like I said ATS has
first-class support for recursion and in
fact it encourages recursion unlike
other systems programming languages so
other systems foreign languages don't
like recursion because it stops over the
C stack this is also true ATS encourages
it because it allows the type checker to
prove things by induction so here's a
factorial function in ATS there's a lot
of group there so let's look at the
essential complexity here there's a
top-level function factorial there's an
inner function loop you kick off loop
with 1.0 and i and as you've all
probably surmised
it's an accumulator that ends up
accumulating inside in that first
argument we parameterize factorial with
an integer we mop and it outputs a
double we modify that integer such that
it always has to be greater than or
equal to 1
you can't call factorial 0 we propagate
that constraint to the inner loop and
the inner loop takes up an accumulator
which is a double and an I which is an
int parameter
that constraints saying it has to be
greater than equal to 1 and this
funny-looking thing
hello more syntax called to a
termination metric a termination metric
the thing inside that angle bracket is a
number or an arithmetic expression that
you have to show the type checker is
strictly decreasing on every recursive
call this is how the type checker knows
that this recursion will eventually
terminate a lot of like C coding
standards don't want you to use
recursion especially for critical code
because you can't prove that the thing
will terminate ATS gives you a way out
of that
so I'm pattern matching on on I don't
worry about why it's case - we'll get to
that in a second or maybe we want I
don't know if it's one just hand back
the accumulator if it's not one when
it's greater than one make the recursive
call multiply the accumulator by I and
decrement I the most interesting thing
about this example is not that it works
is what happens if you leave stuff out
if I leave out that one I is greater
than one that's a type error because
it's going to say you have this
constraint saying that I has to always
be greater than or equal to one more
interestingly if I do anything other
than I minus one if I do I - - if I do I
minus three the solver is smart enough
to say that you might skip right past
one and I can never ever show that this
is going to be greater than or equal to
one if I do I plus one that'll piss off
the termination metric right because now
the thing is not strictly decreasing so
ATS uses recursion to prove useful
things about your programs when in my
opinion most other systems programming
languages stay away from recursion for
good reasons that messes up the API and
all the stuff but I think there's some
good reasons to use it okay so the next
big thing is view types so view types
are this thing that connects linear
resources to algebraic data types
remember
told you 80s was an m/l so we want to be
able to use all of this like functional
programming abstraction goodness to
control these linear resources and
that's what view types do for us so to
see what a view type is here's the
problem this is the swap this is a swap
definition that we saw earlier taking
away some of the duplication here's what
we have we have a type of unknown size
we have an address greater than null we
have a pointer to that address and some
proof that there's something of type a
at that address this comes up a lot
right
I'll pointer to something that you want
to know is not null that has something
inside of it right if we're gonna work
with ATS at a higher level we need to
somehow package all these things up and
the way to do that is with this thing
called a short def and a V type def I
didn't name these things so a sort def
basically takes that constraint and
gives it a name I'm calling it age in
fact I'm not calling it a GZ it's called
a GZ because that stands for address
greater than zero okay and a view type
definition that takes that proof and
that pointer and packages those up
together with a constraint on it that
the address can't be no and we call that
safe pointer and parameterize that with
something okay now okay sorry so this
type signature cleans up to that with
those view type definitions and now we
have a basic building block and we can
create algebra on linear resources this
is a cool thing to have so here is the
the at the algebraic data type of a list
of view types a list of linear resources
cleaning some of this stuff up this
should look relatively familiar so
instead of data type I have data view
type but I still have two constructors
there a no constructor and a cons
constructor and the name of the data
type which is list underscore VT which
is going to be parameterised on a couple
of things
one of which is a beauty at ype I did
not paint this it means a view type of
unknown size and an int the no
constructor takes that thing we passed
in and zero this is a type level number
zero okay the cons constructor takes
that a and an n which is an integer and
hands back the a Andrey curses on that
list view type and decrements a and you
can also provide constraints on that so
basically if you have a linear list of
like one two three right it will be
linear one it'll be list VT cons one
list VT now let's PT cons two lists PT
cons one list VT cons zero at the type
level that's what it would look like
because it's decrementing that at the
type level so here we have how you
construct a linear list list VT cons one
list VP cons to list VT cons no none of
this stuff is really interesting what's
interesting is the type signature which
is usually inferred if this ATS can
actually infer it can infer precious
little but it can infer that right so
it's saying it's a list view type of
type int and there's two things inside
of it cool so what we're gonna do is use
that to make a factorial that preserves
the results in a list so basically if
I'm calling factorial 10 I don't just
want factorial 10 I want 10 times 9 10
times 9 times 8 10 times 9 times 8 times
7 all the way down so the last thing in
my list is going to be factorial 10 I
want to preserve all that stuff and
here's the function that does that so
again removing some of that complexity
the new concept we have here is this new
keyword var var does not mean what var
means in every other language in here
a var means a stack allocated variable
that D compiles to a stack allocated
variable in C that's all of our means it
it doesn't it is mutable but it doesn't
mean mutable it means
allocated and here what we're doing is
saying we're steped allocating a pointer
that is uninitialized and then we have
that function loop that we kick off but
we're returning that var down at the end
so we have a factorial that's
parameterised on some integer that's
modified so it always has to be greater
than equal to two this time not greater
than equal to one I'll get to that in a
second it returns a list view type of a
bunch of doubles where the length of the
list is n minus 1 why I'll get to that
in a second because we're initializing
it with the product of the first and
second thing so if it was a factorial 10
the loop is going to be initialized with
10 times 9 so like that G 0 1 2 to F is
the method name for coerce an integer to
a float I'm sorry
and so we kick off the loop with that
initial thing and then we go i minus 2
because we've already I was already
accounted for the first two things and
then we pass in a reference to that
stack pointer now this is the inner loop
this is just the type signature so let's
step through this so it takes in a next
argument which is what you know what is
the current index of like you know the
factorial that I'm on right now which is
parameterized by N 1 and N 1 is an
integer that's greater than equal to 0
but less than or equal to n minus 2 y n
minus 2 because we kicked off the loop
with I minus 2 right ok cool
so N 1 is also the termination metric
you have to prove that that number is
going down on each recursive call it's
also parameterised on that seed which is
a double and this is cute it's
parameterised and as a result type and
the ampersand means a reference to the
question mark means uninitialized so
this means a reference to a pointer
that's possibly uninitialized that's
what that's what those wanted five
characters mean and it transforms that
into a proof that's what the two arrow
signs mean it keeps getting better don't
worry it doesn't in do it proof that it
is a list of view types of type double
that is of length n 1 plus 1 Y and 1
plus 1 because n 1 goes to n minus 2 and
we want n minus 1 because there's always
one less thing inside of that list than
you pass in and yes this is super
confusing ok I know this is super
confusing and I left it super confusing
for a reason because I can hash all this
out at the type level these are exactly
the kinds of things that go wrong
imagine all the tests that you don't
have to write write these off by one
things happen all the time including in
languages with really strong type
systems as we think of them like
Hezbollah like will have off by one type
errors all of these things will have off
by one type errors rust can have an off
by one type error with refinement types
you cut the number of bugs that you put
into your production code by a lot just
by having that check at the type level
because the type system will not let me
go forward unless I can prove that all
those relationships between those
numbers are sound cool so here's the
inner body of the loop which is
similarly complicated and here are the
arguments for reference so we're pattern
matching on next in the case of zero I'm
just setting the result the the the
stack allocated pointer we passed in to
the seed and nil so if we off all we did
was passed in two it would just multiply
like two times one and hand that back in
a list for the next part I'm going to
take a step back and propose a puzzle
solve this puzzle in a strict functional
programming language pickle doesn't
matter fold over a list and give me a
copy of it
that's all you gotta do make it as
efficient as a while or for loop with an
initial null that has in place mutation
but here's the kicker these are your
constraints
you only get one pass no reversing at
the end you iterate through this
you can't iterate through this list and
start accumulating things and then
reverse it and hand it back to a that's
more than one pass and it's not more
efficient than a while or for loop no
macros no building up like a bunch of
terms than evaluating that in the end
that's cheating no continuations know
building up continuations and evaluating
that at the end which is kind of the
same as the macker but I feel like this
doesn't specify that for this crowd no P
polling no function called copy list
where the body of the function is just a
wild oh that's cheating no weird
optimization pragmas yes I'm aware that
there's like some super smart compilers
out there that you can give like this
magical incantation to you that can make
all this go away that's cheating
I think that this problem is probably
impossible
pick up pick your favorite strict
functional programming language and look
at the implementation of map in it and
see how it does it Milton the standard
ml that is all about performance
reverses so when if you look at the
source code for Milton's list map it
applies a function to everything in the
list and then reverses that list so it's
taking two passes all Camel people's so
a camel has this like mutable
accumulator that it keeps Technion to
the end of that's the same as a while
loop
that's cheating rust uses I think uses
Macker possibly or people's one of the
two or it just writes it in LLVM as for
I don't know right but until recently I
considered all of these things
elegant hacks and now I'm just as
satisfied and by the way people keep
saying that like learning program
programming languages makes you a better
programmer it really doesn't
it makes you a better programmer up to a
point then it makes you bitter and
dissatisfied because you will never be
able to port those ideas to your day job
even if you could get past your the
technical hurdle of your programming
language not supporting those constructs
you will never get there and you will be
bitter and unhappy so you should all
just leave right now like but if you're
gonna stick around
ATS supports this thing called tail
allocation tail allocation is was an
idea that was floated for ML in 1998 and
I learned that because I was researching
you know when I was researching ideas I
came across this idea and it's 20 years
and nobody else has adopted this please
adopt this ok so what is tail allocation
table allocation is a way of punching a
hole in a data structure now punching a
hole that will be filled in later on in
a way you can think of it as a principle
of null pointer but it's not quite that
ok so let's get back to our loop cut out
some of this code and look at that let
block so what we're doing is setting res
which is the return pointer equal to
some list with the seed as the first
thing and this uninitialized hole as the
second thing this underscore on the
right-hand side of an equal to sign
means I'm going to be filling this in
later now we have to actually pattern
match on res to get a hold of that hole
because ATS doesn't give us a way of
like having named holes on in one pass
unfortunately so that underscore is that
hole and then we calculate the next we
calculate the next seed because we have
to use that cheesy g0 want to have
function which courses from an integer
to a float again I apologize and then we
call loop and pass in that hole and
that's the hole to be filled
no nothing's the typo
he's he asked if that plus was a typo
nothing's a typo but I'm just not gonna
tell you what it means because that
that's a rabbit hole so what it really
comes down to is this sort of circular
reference thing res creates a hole the
hole goes back into loop on the next
iteration of loop rest creates another
hole the hole goes back into the loop
and so on and so forth until the zero
sorry
until the zero case on top where it
fills it in with the final seed and a
nil and that's how you get in a TS
folding over a list with this exact same
performance profile as C and in fact you
can even see how that you can even
envision how that would decompile and a
C into c and that's a really powerful
thing to have these kinds of things are
really powerful things to have because
functional programming already has a
reputation for being slow like we have
words like maintainable and stuff like
that but once you say maintainable most
people have just sort of already done
like in C programmers don't care about
that okay so that was my final example
so here's some takeaways ATS is rough
there's no two ways about it this was
just a taste this is the tip of the
iceberg but it contains I think like
very promising glimpses this would be if
a bunch of programming languages took
these ideas and ran with them I think we
would have a great systems for again in
future linear logic is a great idea
I want first-class access to that don't
don't baby me away from linear logic I
want those will proof things that I can
manipulate refinement types great idea
other languages are coming around to it
liquid haskell is one of them the idea
of having a smart type checker and a
dumb compiler is great so that's what
ats is a TS as a front end to see that d
compiles into c code
that you would have written in the first
place or semantically equivalent to that
and this idea of having a front end on a
language that's already widely used I
think is a really good idea like faint
type script but just keep going keep
going like run with that for like the
next 20 years and see what happens I'm
forget about like usability just run
with it yeah and there's a whole bunch
of stuff that I have even talked about
yet 80s is a whole proof level language
it supports proof by induction pattern
matching and everything so for instance
in 80s there's this concept of an array
like it's the same as a CRA basically
you have a bank of proofs that like
these pointers point to these locations
and I can write a type level function
that looks rather like ml that breaks up
that Bank of proofs into two separate
proofs saying that here's a proof going
from index 1 to 5 and here's a proof
coin from index 6 to 10 so the slicing
that other languages provide as a
built-in is you can do it at the proof
level here in ATS because you have that
kind of flexibility so any case that's
my talk here's the repo
I'll there's way more resources I just
didn't have time to add those I will and
thank you for your time and I'll take
any questions
[Applause]